[Rires]
je me suis rendu à kaboul pour la
première fois en janvier 2003 visitez
l'afghanistan à un moment où le pays
ressembler à berlin après la guerre un
pays complètement dévasté par plus de 23
ans de conflit ça a été un tournant dans
ma vie j'ai su que j'allais revenir que
je ferai quelque chose pour aider les
femmes en afghanistan
[Musique]
mais je ne savais pas quoi choisir je
voulais un produit susceptible d'ouvrir
un vrai marché
oui et c'est comme ça qu'on a décidé de
faire des top 6 on s'est tourné vers les
tapis car on s'est aperçu que
culturellement
c'était la seule chose que les femmes
avaient le droit de produire et qui
puisse être un produits exportables
légalement
originaire du texas conny duckworth créa
rue en 2004 et se tourne définitivement
vers le business social au service des
femmes afghanes
une révolution pour celle qui fut
considéré comme une des femmes les plus
influentes de wall street
[Musique]
j'ai travaillé à wall street pendant
vingt ans j'ai été associé avec goldman
sachs qui est la banque d'investissement
la plus influente au monde et je me
trouvais à new york lors des attentats
du 11 septembre
ce jour là j'ai compris que je voulais
changer de vie
en afghanistan elle délègue la direction
de sa société à radiall jeanne une
afghane qui a vécu 30 ans en amérique
c'est elle qui seront sur le terrain
pour rencontrer les familles et dirigé
la société decaux ni sur place bonjour
comment sarah on est de retour on va le
mesurer il doit faire 13 m c'est du très
bon travail salaires très régulier
design et aux états unis pour le marché
occidental
elles sont près de 800 tisserande à
travers le pays a travaillé chez elle
pour faire cette api dans des conditions
qu'aucune femme afghane n'avait jamais
connu elles seront payés 50 dollars le
mètre carré pour ce tapis de 13 mètres
carrés elles toucheront environ 650
dollars ce qui est légèrement au delà du
tarif habituel
de plus on ajoute un bonus correspond à
50% de la somme qu'on leur a versé ce
bonus est liée à la qualité du tapis
qu'elles ont ici
soit environ 1000 euros pour un mois et
demi de travail à quatre personnes dans
une région le salaire moyen est de 50
euros
le quotidien des 800 familles qui
travaillent pour ardue a radicalement
changé
venez venez regarder grâce à l'argent on
a pu acheter une antenne satellite une
télé des matelas des couettes et on a pu
agrandir la maison pour nous et aussi
pour nos animaux
j'ai même pu acheter un beau vélo à mon
fils
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lorsqu elles en sont à faire conny ne
veut pas se contenter d'apporter plus de
travail et d'argent à ces femmes et à
leur famille pour devenir tisserande
chez ardue il faut en accepter les
conditions les conditions sont les
suivantes
elles doivent accepter que tous les
enfants de la famille les filles comme
les garçons ait à l'école
[Musique]
home le tram ça restait tu as quel âge
j'ai 25 ans et à sare ma soeur on a 17
et mon frère 14
ils vont à l'école non pourquoi mon
frère a dû arrêter pour travailler il
fait des petits boulots
maintenant vous allez gagner de l'argent
avec nous il doit donc retourner à
l'école en plus de ça les femmes doivent
suivre des cours d'alphabétisation que
nous organisons la plupart du temps dans
la maison
les femmes doivent suivre ses cours deux
heures par jour six jours par semaine
depuis le début les profits d'argent
sont réinvestis en priorité dans
l'éducation des femmes et des enfants
mais aussi dans leur santé tous les
frais médicaux des familles sont prises
en charge par la compagnie et pour aller
plus loin conny vient de faire
construire un centre pour femmes
lieu de rencontre et d'apprentissage qui
leur est réservé une première en
afghanistan
[Musique]
sortez vos cahiers vos livres et posez
les sur la table 70% d'illettrisme dans
le pays et près de 90 % parmi les femmes
en six ans elles sont déjà plus de 5000
à avoir suivi ses cours
5000 femmes qui sont désormais parmi les
rares femmes de ce pays à savoir lire et
écrire
savoir lire et écrire c'est utile pour
tous par exemple je peux trouver seul
mon chemin dans la rue je peux savoir
comment je dois prendre mes médicaments
et surtout je peux aider mes enfants à
faire leurs devoirs
ici on forme aussi des institutrices
pour aller enseigner dans les nombreux
villages sans écoles à travers le pays
le centre comprend aussi un salon de thé
ont droit unique où ces femmes peuvent
se rencontrer et se parler librement
il ya aussi une laverie la seule dans
cette région où elle lave habituellement
leur linge dans la rivière et surtout
des ateliers de formation
[Musique]
lance aujourd'hui on va apprendre à
faire un gâteau à la banane vous allez
avoir besoin bien sûr de bananes de
farine sont d'huile du beurre et de la
levure et bien sûr un peu de sel
[Musique]
on a commencé un programme
d'apprentissage en pâtisserie notre
espoir c'est que dans un avenir proche
certaines de ces femmes puissent ouvrir
leurs propres entreprises qu'elles
pourront commencer depuis ici puis on
les aidera à s'établir notre objectif
c'est que leur vie et celle de leur
famille change pour le meilleur
nous on va tout mettre à leur
disposition pour qu'elles exploitent au
mieux leur potentiel et qu'elles
puissent prendre leur avenir en main
pour les aider à organiser leur avenir
razia est en train d'installer un
semblant du sinn au sein du centre pour
apprendre à ces femmes qu'il est
possible de travailler en dehors de chez
elle ici on va pouvoir faire travailler
une vingtaine de femmes ce qui était
inenvisageable avant car elle n'avait
pas le droit de sortir de chez elle avec
le temps les maris ont appris à nous
faire confiance et ils acceptent que
leurs femmes viennent ici pour utiliser
prochainement cette salle de tissage de
8h à 16h
en attendant comme le bilan de l'année
fut bon ardue a pu construire le premier
parc de jeux dans la région un lieu de
plus pour améliorer la vie de ces femmes
et de ces enfants
lorsqu'on a commencé je n'aurais
vraiment pas pu vous dire où ça allait
nous mener le cas mais maintenant je le
vois clairement je suis convaincu que le
business un rôle majeur à jouer un rôle
constructif et positif
le business peut changer le monde
[Musique]
sachant baisse des entreprises sociales
transforme les par transformer je veux
dire qu'elle sauve des vies
[Musique]